once again it was f five o'clock
yesterday afternoon the Trump
administration continues to basically be
in disarray I don't know exactly what
other language I should use it relates
to staffing it relates to Russia it
relates to resignations and firings and
this time it's the latest communications
director in a long string of
communications directors hope Hicks who
is 29 years old she's been with Donald
Trump since pretty early on in his
presidential campaign in 2016 she has
worked for Ivanka Trump she is
shockingly one of the longest-serving
Trump staffers and she's resigning now
why does she say she's resigning because
she feels she's accomplished everything
she could in the job there's never a
perfect time to leave but for her the
time to leave is soon it already makes
no sense because I can't think of
anything that hope Hipp Hicks
accomplished as a trump staffer I just
it's just hard to buy that explanation
she wants to pursue other opportunities
but when you're 29 years old and the
communications director yeah that's a
good opportunity that's a that's a great
opportunity she's in the good
opportunity there's always more to
everything though right the the list of
interesting timing is very very long
first of all she announced her
resignation the day after she was
questioned for eight hours by the House
Intelligence Committee looking into
Trump Russia collusion during which she
admitted yes she would occasionally lie
as part of her work for Donald Trump but
she never lied about anything related to
Russia of course not I believe her
of course everyone that's being asked
about the timing she testifies for eight
hours she doesn't answer a lot of stuff
as we heard from Democrats who were in
the room and then now we learn of her
resignation very coincidental timing
staffers at the White House are saying
it has nothing whatsoever to do with the
Russia testimony but does anybody really
believe that we're told she was planning
this resignation for a while and that
this is just a coincidence as to when
it's happening maybe it's possible that
she fears indictment right that's sort
of like the
level easy question to ask is she
worried about getting indicted and thus
is she trying to sort of create some
distance between herself and the Trump
administration or is she positioning
herself to maybe flip at some point is
it possible that the eight hours of
testimony made it so that she realized
she just cannot tolerate defending the
administration any longer now I don't
think it's that last one and I honestly
don't know what it is but it's very
difficult to believe the timing
coincidence and that the resignation has
zero whatsoever to do with the fact that
she was grilled for eight hours by the
House Intelligence Committee about her
role and knowledge of the Trump Russia
possible crimes that are being
investigated now the other question is
sort of not more cynical necessarily but
the question is does she already have an
agreement with Robert Muller of some
kind which included going and testifying
before the House Intelligence Committee
not answering more than what she
absolutely can't get away declining to
answer and then saying that she's going
to leave the administration again we
don't know there's also the case in
terms of possible criminality by hope
Hicks there's not a there's a relatively
strong case that you could eventually
see an obstruction charge against hope
Hicks after all she was involved in that
statement that Donald Trump jr. gave the
first statement which was all lies about
the infamous Trump Tower meeting does
she have a role there that could lead to
an indictment we don't know but the
smartest thing for her to do if she does
think she's exposed to an indictment and
how would she not be at this point would
be talked to Moeller before testifying
at the House Intelligence Committee and
then create some kind of a path forward
I don't know I don't know what the
explanation it's a little hard to
speculate because hope Hicks wasn't
really in the public spotlight now which
is surprising for a communications
director but yeah we didn't see her give
speeches I don't think that testimony
was in a public setting it was not
behind closed doors yes it was and she
also mean now we're getting sort of
further
away and it's almost like it's almost
tabloid like as Pat was saying before
the show but it's relevant to what's
going on which is what is going on in
terms of the Rob Porter connections we
told you that Rob Porter resigned a few
weeks ago after news broke that he was
accused of beating multiple ex-wives and
he wasn't gonna be able to get a
security clearance hope Hicks had been
dating Rob Porter and I mentioned it at
the time that Hicks staying in the Trump
administration could kind of get weird
well not only is she leaving but a week
ago she also separated from Rob Porter
again I don't know what's going on what
we do know is that according to
everybody in the room for her testimony
Monday there was nothing she said that
even hinted at the idea that she might
be separating from the Trump
administration and the question is sort
of at the 30,000 foot level is what's
the impact right I mean first of all
it's nuts that a 29 year old former
child model with no experience at all in
politics was up until now one of the
longest-serving Trump staffers right
that is an indication of how backwards
things are but more broadly we're gonna
put up on the screen a partial list of
some of the Trump administration
officials that have either been fired or
resigned and again this is only a
partial list plus all the people that
resign from various committees including
people like Elon Musk and advisers when
Trump said he would hire only the best
people are those the ones that are still
there or are those the ones that are
leaving like is this the list of good
people and they're too good for Trump or
are these the bad ones that he said he
wouldn't be hiring but the people that
remain are the good what's really hard
to say I think you should read through
that list to the tune of Sarah
McLaughlin's in the arms of an angel all
right yes we should have some kind of a
montage a monta an emotional montage of
all the good people great people
according to Trump that we've lost so
hope Hicks another one bites the dust
will we ever really find out what caused
the timing of this resignation maybe we
actually might I mean there are multiple
invasion investigations going on that
are interested in what hope Hicks knows
and when she learned it so maybe we will
someday find out the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership